(faint background talking)
- I know barely anything.
- Like a shoelace.
- [Man] You're wearing a shoelace.
- Okay.
- [Man] We could probably hide this.
- Yeah.
- [Man] Look at that.
- Perfect!
Will it be muffled or anything?
- [Man] I don't think so.
- Okay.
- [Man] It should be fine.
- [Interviewer] All right, Sommer.
- [Sommer] Okay.
- [Interviewer] Sommer,
where are you from originally?
- [Sommer] I'm from San Francisco.
- [Interviewer] And tell
me about your family.
You grew up with both your parents?
- [Sommer] Yes, I did.
- [Interviewer] And, tell
me about your childhood.
- Ummm...
- [Interviewer] You were
a good kid, bad kid?
- Bad kid...
- [Interviewer] (laughs)
- Got in a lot of trouble.
Not a lot of trouble,
I was grounded a lot.
But, just as I would like,
Sneak out, I had like bad grades, steal...
Just things like that, nothing too crazy.
But yeah.
- [Interviewer] And did
you finish high school?
- I didn't.
So like, two days before...
or like a day before graduation,
I had my cap and gown and everything,
but I was really bad at math.
So, me failing my math final, basically,
I just couldn't graduate.
So I was super devastated, super sad.
But I did end up going to adult school
to get my actual diploma not my GED.
- [Interviewer] Okay.
- So, I never really cared for school
I feel like the things
that they were teaching
like didn't really,
I didn't care about any of them.
I was obviously good
at like art, ceramics,
all like the fun classes.
But, I was good at English too,
but like you know, just the
harder classes I just was so...
never did my homework,
never really took notes.
Yeah, so.
- [Interviewer] And then after
high school, where'd you go?
- After high school,
where did I go?
I moved out of my mom's
house like, three days after
I turned 18, so,
and then I met a boyfriend,
and lived with him
for three years, and that
was cool and stuff, but...
Yeah 20, right before I turned 21...
Yeah I kind of just left him
and then started doing my own thing.
- [Interviewer] And what
does your own thing entail?
- So I got into porn.
So...
I've stripped a little
throughout those three years,
if me and him were just not working out,
and I'd go stay somewhere
else, I'd be like,
"Cool let me just go strip really quick",
and so I went.
- [Interviewer] Make
some money.
- Yeah, make some money.
It was fun, it was like exciting,
but it was like very,
it was like hard for me.
It's a lot of like, physical work.
There's days where you may
not get paid that well,
it was just a lot.
You know, coming from
someone that has had jobs,
but never really had to have a job,
it was like...
It was like...
what's the word?
It was just frustrating.
So, yeah, I got into porn.
And yeah, it was cool.
You know, 'cause when you're the new girl,
there's a lot of, a lot of work for you,
I was turning a lot down too,
just 'cause I was like,
trying to kind of keep it a secret,
and like, maintain an image,
just in case, like my parents found out,
or like, my ex found out.
Yeah, so, I mean, so I haven't
shot that much as of now.
I don't know why, I really don't know why.
I mean, now I'm shooting a little bit more
but that's why I'm kinda
going back and forth
between like, dancing,
or like web-camming.
You know, everything within that industry.
But I heard these days it's
just kind of hard for everyone,
to make money just off of porn alone.
Just because of,
you know, all the pirating,
and all these other
sites, where you can...
[Interviewer] Yeah
technology has changed that.
- Yeah, it's, you don't really, yeah.
No one really sells DVDs anymore,
everything is online.
So, therefore a lot of stuff gets leaked.
My stuff's been leaked, I can like,
I'll look myself up,
and I'll see people
like, screen recording,
like, so you have to watermark, it's just,
it kinda sucks, but it's kinda cool
if you know how to,
you know, how to kind of play the game.
And you're tech savvy I guess.
- [Interviewer] Right.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] What are the best things
and the worst things about
working in the sex industry?
- I think some of the
best things are just like,
the independence, and the freedom you get.
I've kind of just like,
you know, like today, I'm just like,
"Hey, I got nothing going on...
"you know, I may have something
going on later tonight,
but let me just...",
you know, the freedom.
I could never really see myself working
a nine to five again.
Just because I love the flexibility.
Maybe, I guess the money,
when things are going good.
Because for instance,
at a regular job,
you're not gonna make, you know,
a thousand or something a day.
You're not.
And that's also the problem,
to where it's like,
I can't see myself working
a regular job again,
because it's like, I'd
be like "this is it,
"this is my check?".
And you know but,
so, some of the worst
things I think are just,
like the way you get perceived
if you're not a stronger person,
or you don't have a tougher skin.
It can be very like, detrimental
to your mental health.
It can be very hard on your body.
Like I said, your mental health.
Your relationships
outside of the industry.
Like, I really don't think
I'll have a boyfriend
for a while, which is, I'm
totally fine with that now,
'cause I've been,
in like, a super long
relationship and stuff.
But yeah, it's...
that can, some people can't
handle that, you know?
Your family,
may like, isolate you, may
look at you differently.
My family is kinda like,
"cool, she's making her own money.
"Be safe."
- [Interviewer] So your family
knows you're doing this?
- [Sommer] Oh yeah (laughs)
Yeah, some unrelated person
was like, "is this such and such?".
And I'm like, weirdo why are you?
You know, can we focus on the fact
that he's like watching me?
And not, you know, I'm like,
I'm an adult, I'm like 22 years old.
Like, I can make my own, and I'm safe.
And I'm doing pretty well.
I live in the valley,
I don't have any roommates,
I have a nice car.
So I'm...
I'm okay.
But everyone kinda has this stigma
that any girl that's in
this industry is like,
being like sex trafficked,
or she has a pimp,
and it's like not really.
Like, I'm just like a normal girl
that likes to make,
to likes to just,
you know what I mean?
I'm open with my sexuality.
I always kind of like,
was like,
not a sexual person,
but it's like, I was always
using my image somehow,
to get me somewhere.
And I was like, "well,
why not get paid for it?".
So, you know?
But yeah, so my parents know.
And...
- [Interviewer] What was
their reaction?
- [Sommer] My mom was like,
"Is this what you were doing
in Miami when you told me
"you were modeling?"
And I'm like, "yeah." (laughs)
I was like, "That's what I was doing."
'Cause I remember I'd come home,
I'd leave with like no makeup,
and I'd either come home
with no makeup again,
or I'd just,
I'd look like really tired,
and exhausted.
And like my hair would obviously
not be perfectly straight
anymore, it just,
or I'd come home at like, 10 at night,
after leaving at like 7AM, or 10AM.
So, I don't know, but I think like now,
like, she's just honestly
glad that like I'm
keeping her in the loop.
You know, 'cause growing up,
like me being in trouble a lot.
I wasn't really like, I'd
be like "I hate my mom,
"and blah blah blah".
But, now its like,
I really am just grateful
that she's just like,
"hey, like what's going on with that?"
And I'll tell her.
You know, and she's not,
like a,
am I allowed to cuss?
- [Interviewer] Of course.
- [Sommer] She's not a bitch about it.
You know what I mean?
I've heard about girls
getting like disowned,
or like,
just stuff like that and I'm like,
I'm really grateful for that,
that I don't have to go through that,
because it would really suck, you know?
So.
- [Interviewer] And are drugs
things you'd play around with, or no?
- [Sommer] Hmm?
- [Interviewer] You play
around with drugs, at all?
- [Sommer] I smoke weed, I like to drink.
I like to drink wine.
I'll go out on the weekends,
have my little, you know,
tequila grapefruit, like...
- [Interviewer] But
nothing out of control?
- [Sommer] No, because I feel like,
like, me living alone,
and you know, having a,
like always have a good
head on my shoulders,
I can't afford,
to like, not be on my A-game, you know?
I actually stopped smoking weed a lot,
because it would make me just like,
eat a lot of food.
And like, me being kinda naked
all the time, it was not,
you know and it's just,
I just,
I go through my phases.
But,
you know, I think I'm just also growing up
to where I'm like "eh, this
isn't really beneficial
"for me to like, smoke weed all
day, or drink wine all day."
Like, you know what I mean, so.
Don't get me wrong, I'll probably go get
a cocktail after this, why not, for lunch.
(laughs) You know what I mean?
But like, yeah, there are a lot of girls
who do whatever they have to do.
Like, I believe in doing
whatever you have to do
to make your money,
and to get by in life,
as long as you're safe.
But to each his own.
But, I just also am like a little scared
of like being here in LA like,
you never know, like you can't
just take drugs from anybody,
and I'd rather just be safe and like,
not do anything at all.
Or, you know so, I'll go to
the dispensary and get my weed,
I don't buy street weed or...
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- You know, like I remember one time,
I guess, I like blacked
out the second time ever.
First time was in high school.
I thought I was roofied,
'cause like, I left my
drink unattended for like,
the first time ever, I
always, always always always,
'cause I go out, young attractive girl,
Cover my drink,
or just bring it with me
or just leave it there,
finish it, leave it, and get another one.
And I asked the bartender,
"can you get me another one?"
She's like, "fine...",
like being a bitch and I'm
like, do you not realize,
how many guys are here that
could just pop something
in my drink, like?
Shit like that.
So yeah.
I don't know, but I
had pre-gamed with wine
at my apartment, then I went
out and was taking shots
of tequila, so I guess I did black out.
My friends were like,
"You're fine, Sommer, like,
"you don't remember, but
you threw up in the uber."
And I'm like "what?"
Like, just stuff like that
I don't like happening,
'cause if I don't remember, its like,
I don't wanna embarrass myself,
I don't wanna put myself in danger,
just stuff like that.
Like, I watch a lot of crime TV, so.
I kinda scare myself into, you know...
- [Interviewer] (laughs)
- Not doing things like that.
- [Interviewer] Great.
- So, yeah.
- [Interviewer] Does this
career ever get you down?
- Yeah, it's, it is
pretty like, depressing.
Because like, for me, not shoot-,
it's not depressing all the time.
There was a point, where I was like,
"why am I not getting any work,
like why are all these other
"girls getting work and I'm not?
"Like, aren't I pretty, aren't
I, don't I have the look?"
And like,
so I would go through
like changing my hair,
changing my makeup, like,
changing everything and
it still wouldn't work.
So, there was a point, like,
and that's when I was
smoking weed everyday,
and like drinking wine everyday, and just,
unhealthy, just like,
I was also in like, a toxic relationship,
just like, I was not happy.
And I just feel like,
and I was also living in Vegas.
And so, me moving to
LA kinda just gave me,
like a different hope.
Like, I was just like, look like,
I'm here, I'm gonna make the best of it.
But, I was just like,
I can't live like that.
Like, no one's ever gonna book me,
if I am not taking care of myself.
So, it was just, it made
me just feel really bad.
You know, it made me feel like,
like just really down.
But you know, my thing was,
let me take advantage
of the new technology,
like the premium Snapchat,
the OnlyFans,
the "swipe up" features on Instagram,
and not focus so much on doing porn.
That's when I got back into the stripping.
Because that also boosted my self esteem,
because I knew,
I was one of the prettiest
girls at the club.
And it wasn't just my look, it was just,
I was friendly, I was bubbly,
I'm not, I don't, I'm
not the best at the pole.
You know, I'll try and
dance when I have to,
but like, it's like,
me like, not focusing on that 100%,
and like, putting my energy
into something that I could
still make money off of,
that could boost my self esteem,
make me feel sexy still,
that definitely helped me.
And then not being in
the house all the time,
like I have all these little
outfits just sitting there.
I'm like, "let me like
go out and be like, naked
"and get some compliments."
You know what I mean, and get paid for it.
You know, 'cause when you're sitting there
and seeing all these other
girls getting booked,
and I'm like, and no offense, like,
they're not always the prettiest girls.
I had to get off my phone,
I had to get off Twitter,
I had to just, go live life.
So...
Yeah, yeah, so that's why
I dabble a little bit,
and even the webcam thing,
like there's always something
I feel like you could do in this industry.
You know, you can't focus on one thing.
Unless you're literally shooting like,
what like, at least like,
like six to eight times a month at least.
- [Interiewer] Hmm-mm.
- You know?
And that's not really common for like,
black girls, I'm realizing,
either, which is weird,
'cause I think we're very popular
in pop culture these days.
Like, a lot of people,
like emulate our styles,
a lot of people wanna
get the super tan skin,
and wear bamboo hoop earrings,
and like, you know what
I mean, get the big butts
and yet we're not
getting any love in porn.
But I'm like, "doesn't
everybody wanna kinda fuck us?"
You know what I mean,
like you know what I mean?
So, I don't know but,
it is what it is, its life, you know?
- [Interviewer] What do you
prefer, stripping or porn?
- I don't know, 'cause I
like the glamor of stripping.
There's a glamor to it, like,
I like the sparkly big heels,
and like obviously these outfits,
and the long, just the
majestic-ness of like,
you know, like, not like
the ratchet stripper,
but like, Vegas stripper glam.
So, living in Vegas, it's just like the,
you know, there is a glamor to it.
So, I love that aspect of it.
So, I think I prefer that,
but then I also love how in porn,
'cause I modeled for three years normally
before getting into any sex work.
So, I like the aspect of porn,
where you come get you
makeup and hair done,
you get your pretty girl, so you like,
get all these free photos,
and then, you know, you're just,
they make you look good, most of the time,
unless the scene is to make
you look like, like shit.
You know what I mean?
But, so I like both, but there is a,
that's why I go back and forth.
'Cause I'll always make it glamorous,
'cause that's just the
way I like to dress,
and like, I like to be really girly,
but I do prefer,
porn, just because its less work.
It really is less work.
Stripping, you have to have a mouth piece.
I can be kinda shy and reserved.
Like, I don't bum rush a guy, at the ATM.
I'll kinda just sit and like,
"oh, I'll let him come to
me", you know what I mean?
And that's kind of why I
would get a little frustrated
and just stop for a while.
Because it was way more of a hustle,
it was way more of like, hard work.
And then with porn, its
like, hey, set rate,
come in, get paid, sign your, and go home.
You get fucked and go home.
And, it sounds a little bad, but its not.
(laughs)
It sounds a little, just
to be, you know, fair,
it's not as gruesome, as
"get fucked, go home".
It's work, but, I would prefer
to just be a full time porn star,
but I don't have that luxury, right now.
So.
- [Interviewer] All right Sommer,
well thank you so much for,
sharing your story.
- You're welcome.
- [Sommer] Oh, that was fun.
- [Interviewer] (laughs)
- [Sommer] I actually liked that.
(giggles)
- [Interviewer] A little
different from what you're,
- [Sommer] No, I liked it though.
It's, I like it, I like it.
I don't do many interviews.
And I have people tell me like,
"Oh she's one of the like,
"more articulate porn stars,
"and I wanna see her talk more."
And I'm like, wow!
Like, so that does help
too, that does help too.
Just to know that, you know.
'Cause no one ever really hears me talk.
- [Interviewer] No, no.
Unless I'm reading like,
a filthy script,
like, you were saying "fuck
me", you know what I mean?
And that doesn't sound the
best, so, yeah, yeah, awesome.